this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant a
problem-solving website that teaches you
to think like an engineer the time has
finally arrived
the comment section demanding imperial
and metric units
has gone on too long there can only be
one measurement system
the british imperial system like
everything british is based on
antiquated
units of measurement like measuring your
country's importance by counting the
number of countries you have invaded
and pillaged a measurement that made
sense 100 years ago but
it's time to move on weirdly the british
have mostly moved on
from this method of measurement and it
is instead
americans who insist on holding onto it
well america liberia and myanmar a
prestigious trio
now i can already hear the people who
refuse to wear masks in the comments
there are two kinds of countries those
that use the metric system
and those that landed on the moon you
know who led the design team for the
saturn v
this guy listen to that deep alabama
accent
this weight dictates the amount of fuel
and the numbers of motors
an american through and through ignore
this photo of him
those are just some german friends he
made while on gap year in europe
look at all his friends let's count them
one
two three four five
six seven eight
[Music]
nine friends a popular man this alabama
native
used metric in fact he despised british
units
so much so that he designed a rocket
during his gap year to fly to england
to show them how great the metric system
was the saturn v
was designed like nearly everything in
nasa at the time
with a mixture of both metric and
imperial units
just read the mission reports for apollo
11 for proof of this
it switches between inches and
centimeters constantly
it's a mess anyone working with this
report
would have had to be hyper aware of what
unit of measurement
they were using most of the design and
science work was done
in metric before being converted to
imperial for the manufacturing and
operational staff
one of the most mind-boggling examples
of this is the guidance computer
it was coded in metric meters and
kilograms
are the language of science but to
ensure the astronauts could intuitively
understand
what those calculations meant the
displays inside the lunar module
had to be displayed in british imperial
units
so even back then when computer power
was extremely limited
the engineers had to waste precious
computational time
and power to conversion this isn't just
a waste of computation power
errors in conversion have led to an
insane number of accidents through the
years
some of the most notable being in nasa
in december 1998
the mars climate orbiter took off from
cape canaveral
aboard its delta ii rocket over the
course of its nine and a half month
journey
the orbiter needed to complete
trajectory correction maneuvers
to bring it into an optimal orbit
insertion altitude
of 226 kilometers however
as the time grew closer calculations
showed that the orbiter was entering
mars orbit
in a far lower altitude so low that it
was likely going to strike the
atmosphere
and violently tear itself apart this is
exactly
what happened so what went wrong
the orbiter was coated with metric units
so
the thruster control unit was working
with the metric unit for impulse
newton seconds but the controller was
being supplied
with pound four seconds which differs by
a conversion factor
of 4.45 a massive discrepancy
a discrepancy that destroyed a 328
million dollar project
in 1983 an air canada flight departing
from montreal
ran out of fuel halfway to its
destination in edmonton
why the ground crew knew 22 500
kilograms of fuel
was needed for the flight they however
needed to calculate how many liters were
needed
to be pumped so they used the density
ratio to convert the weight measurement
to a volume measurement but they used
the 1.77 density ratio
which was pounds per liter instead of
the correct ratio of 0.8 kilograms per
liter
resulting in less than half the required
fuel load being pumped aboard
luckily the pilot managed to glide the
plane down to an abandoned airfield
but that little boo-boo of a conversion
error could have resulted in a
catastrophic loss of life
these are two cautionary tales with
disastrous consequences
but it tells you nothing of the silent
screams into the void
every engineer in the world lets out
when they are forced to work with both
units
it's just an unnecessary pain in the ass
we could all do without
this is the reason we need to choose one
measurement system mixing units
not only is tempting fate with
conversion errors but it cost an
untold number of hours for scientists
and engineers around the world
banging their head against tables when
they could be using that time for
something more productive
i could end the video there but we need
to really hammer home why metric units
are the superior units so
why is it better well let's start with a
fundamental unit of measurement
there are seven base units of
measurement and with these seven
we can measure everything in the
universe think of them like the three
primary colors of light with these three
colors we can create
any color in the universe by mixing them
in just the correct proportions
we can do the same with these
fundamental units of measurement
they are time length mass temperature
electric current chemical amount and
luminous intensity
with these measures we can describe our
universe
velocity is a combination of length and
time volume
is length cubed density is volume
combined with mass
these measurements are the language of
the universe
so let's see how the imperial system
handles a very simple one
length an inch is a standard unit of
measurement for length
in the imperial system let's imagine a
scenario
you are designing a railing for a one
mile long bridge
you as a skilled and knowledgeable
engineer
know that two half inch bolts are more
than enough to secure the railing down
the posts of the railing are six feet
apart alright
how many inches are there in a foot 12
so that's 72 inches every 72 inches we
need two bolts
our bridge is one mile long how many
feet is that
i don't know off the top of my head and
a quick google search tells me it's 5280
feet
what's 12 inches by 5080 that's 63
360 inches divide that by 72
that's 880 so we need to order 1760 half
inch bolts
that felt cumbersome why do i need to
remember all these numbers
because imperial is a convoluted mess of
measurement units
invented by people who married their
cousins that's why
now let's see how much easier that is in
metric
how many millimeters are there in a
meter it's in the name
milli one thousand now how many meters
are there in a kilometer
once again it's in the dam name kilo
1000
given a measurement in kilometers but
want meters
just shift the decimal place over three
places no calculation needed
there is no room for error it's a simply
better system
even within imperial you have to
constantly convert your units
ounces to pounds pounds to imperial tons
which for some reason
differs from a metric ton by 1.6
again in metric there are 1000 grams in
a kilogram and 1 000 kilograms in a ton
in imperial there are 16 ounces in a
pound and 2
240 pounds in an imperial ton why
you aren't even following the same
conversion conventions
as your other units this is insanely
cumbersome
the chances of converging errors even
within your own damn system is high
never mind having to convert to metric
you know what's even more insane
the word for mass and weight in the
imperial system
is the same why because the pound was
invented
before we knew what gravity was that's
why
we just assumed mass and weight were the
same thing
when they aren't so we have to specify
in imperial
whether we mean pound mass or pound
force
i haven't been this confused since i
watched magic mic
the most ridiculous thing about all of
this every single one of these imperial
measurements are legally defined
by the metric system america is already
using the metric system
and most of the population is oblivious
to it
freedom murica guns pew pew
ura the foot is legally defined
as 0.3048 meters the pound is illegally
defined
by 0.435 kilograms why
because the metric system is run by the
international bureau of weights and
measures
a neutral international organization
whose sole mission is to create
a global language of science who america
is a member of and they have succeeded
in an awe-inspiring way
in 2019 the final metric base unit the
kilogram
stopped being defined by human artifacts
and is now
like all other metric units defined by
the laws
of physics in 2019 it ceased being
defined by this hunk of metal
and began being defined by planck's
constant which is defined as 6.6
to 6 by 10 to the minus 34 kilogram
meter squared per second
of course to use this as a definition we
need ways to define the meter and second
the meter is defined as the length of
the path traveled by light
in a vacuum in one divided by 299
million
792 458 of a second okay
so how do we define a second a second is
defined by the hyperfine transition
frequency which is the frequency of
radiation which will cause an electron
to jump from two
closely spaced low energy states in a
cesium-133 atom
each of the base units are defined like
this
using the unchanging language of the
universe
as its yardstick or should i say meter
stick
it's a beautiful and inspiring language
that transcends the realm of humans
and for that reason alone you should
strive to use the metric system
understanding the language of the
universe is a superpower
and there is no better place to become
fluent in that language
then brilliant did you know that you can
measure literally
anything you can even measure what you
don't know which is something i learned
through brilliant brand new course
knowledge and uncertainty you
intuitively know that knowing the
weather
30 days from now is more uncertain than
the result of a roll of a dice
and a roll of the dice is more uncertain
than a coin flip
but why we can't physically measure them
with a ruler or scale
being able to quantify uncertainty and
know how to decrease it with information
is an incredibly valuable skill and this
course will teach you
everything you need to know or if this
course is not your flavor
you could learn math with the people
that invented it with their other brand
new course
math history this journey of problem
solving unpacks the first algorithms for
finding primes
the original ideas behind imaginary
numbers and how ancient patterns have
made their way
into modern mathematics these are just
two of many courses on brilliant
that will improve your ability to
understand the world around you
if you are naturally curious want to
build your problem-solving skills
or need to develop confidence in your
analytical abilities
then get brilliant premium to learn
something new every day
brilliant thought-provoking math science
and computer science content
helps guide you to mastery by taking
complex concepts and breaking them up
into bite-sized
understandable chunks you'll start by
having fun with their interactive
explorations
and over time you'll be amazed at what
you can accomplish
as always thanks for watching and thank
you to all my patreon supporters
if you'd like to see more from me the
links to my twitter instagram
discord server and subreddit are below